so Nintendo's making a shooter splatoon
it's called and I've played a bunch of
the review version we got here prior to
release I dabbled in the single-player
mode but I've mostly been sticking to
the competitive multiplayer I really
like competitive multiplayer shooters
and splatoon is a competitive
multiplayer shooter but shooting isn't
really the point a shooter in which
shooting isn't the point yeah it's weird
to think about it that way like what
does that even mean on a basic level it
means that you have a primary goal that
isn't just vanquish the other team you
got to paint the ground and the team
that covers the most area in their color
by the time the round ends wins but
plenty of other shooters have modes with
different objectives like capture and
hold the place or carry the thing from
the place to the other place these still
end up being mostly about shooting your
opponents or at least they feel like
that the majority of the time holding a
position is just waiting to kill
somebody and carrying a flag is just
running from somebody's that want to
kill you okay yes that's a little
reductive but still the lion's share of
the gameplay complexity most of your
experience of actually playing the game
is tied up in the competitive dynamic of
shooting and I think that's a big part
of what makes a shooter a shooter in
splatoon has that you can totally blast
your enemies into squiggly oblivion to
do so well requires weapon tactics
environmental knowledge and movement
savvy you need to account for what you
can do and what your target can do and
then you need to do all of that better
than the person trying to do all of that
to you on a fundamental level that's
what you're doing in most other
competitive shooters the complexity of
humans trying to shoot other humans in
digital combat is there but the thing
that's also there the thing that makes
splatoon a shooter that's not really
about the shooting is the painting the
main objective not just that it's there
but that it too is complex painting
requires map awareness what routes are
important to control where the large
swathes of territory you can paint
quickly at the last minute which walls
are worth painting even though they
don't count towards your total and so on
painting requires that you plan your
loadout well and play To Your Strengths
using your weapon and special
us to cover as much area as you can
while supporting your strategy with
appropriate perks painting requires that
you maneuver smartly and replenish your
ink reserves regularly both of which are
entwined with a crucial art of swimming
and you need to do all of that better
than the person trying to do all of that
to you so I guess it's not that splatoon
isn't about shooting because it is it's
that splatoon is about more than just
shooting a large portion of the gameplay
complexity and a big part of your
experience of actually playing the game
is tied up in the competitive dynamic of
painting oh and the painting is pretty
damn satisfying is it as satisfying as a
well-placed headshot it might be if a
headshot is a moment of mastery within
the shooting mechanics of a game then
what does similar mastery of painting
mechanics look like well I'll tell you
it's a lot of splattered paint a huge
swath of your color at the end of a
round and a triumphant smile on your
adorable squiggly little face
you